[Music]
what would happen if every microbe in
the world just disappeared could we live
could anything live and for how long
[Music]
first let's talk about mass extinctions
the first microbes on this planet
appeared billions of years ago in the
long history of life since then
researchers have estimated using fossil
evidence that there have been five major
mass extinctions these extinctions were
catastrophic mixes of geological
biological and of course on at least one
occasion astronomical issues that over
the often protracted period they
occurred killed off a large percentage
of extant species the end-permian
extinction which is considered to be the
largest mass extinction occurred over
252 million years ago the result of
volcanic activity that produced
greenhouse gases and warmth planet but
more recently researchers have
identified another potential culprit
microbes specifically methanogens a type
of methane producing archaea whose
numbers may have increased as they fed
on dying plants and animals creating
even more methane that warmed the planet
further killing more organisms producing
more food for methanogens a classic
positive feedback loop that changed the
planet too fast for many species to cope
with now this idea that microbes may
have been involved in the largest mass
extinction is a hypothesis rooted in
scientific observation but still not
proven but as we look and what a world
without microbes might be like remember
that they may have at least once done
living systems a good deal of damage
all on their own but a world without
them I would do far more damage with
this thought and perhaps our own biases
in mind the collective scientific
understanding of microbes feels a bit
like being in love it wasn't long ago
that we didn't know they existed but now
it's hard to imagine a world without
them now this has not stopped scientists
from trying to imagine such a world in
2014
Jack a Gilbert and Josh Dean Newfield
published a paper in PLoS Biology called
life in a world without microbes
envisioning a hypothetical world where
in a single moment all microbes vanish
their thought experiment uses what we've
learned of microbes to take on a belief
put forth by Louis Pasteur that quote
life would not long remain possible in
the absence of microbes and that may
have been the case then but we have more
technology now there are many ways to
explore this hypothetical world without
microbes and in their work Gilbert and
Newfield consider what we might broadly
group into two questions what would an
absence of microbes do to the world
around us and what would an absence of
microbes do to the world inside of us
let's start with that second question
the internal one if all microbes
single-celled and multi-celled were to
vanish there would be a large number of
diseases that would just cease to exist
now in this hypothetical mitochondria
and similar endosymbiotic prokaryotes
that have long been integrated into
multicellular eukaryotic bodies such as
our own are treated not as microbes but
as part of our bodies if all
mitochondria disappeared - do not fear
you would be dead that very instant but
even without endosymbionts that leaves
many many microbes inside of us
particularly the bacteria in our gut
that
in digestion and metabolism it's
unlikely that we will ever know for sure
what would happen to our bodies if all
of those microbial residents were just
suddenly evicted the examples we can
take from various types of germ-free
animals that have been raised since the
end of the 19th century suggests that
life at least inside of us will still go
on it's just not clear what that life
would look like for us we would likely
have to rely on synthetic nutrients to
compensate for changes in how our body
processes food meanwhile our own
physiology might change we would for
example be smaller having access to
fewer nutrients leaving us to wonder
what of our body belonged just to us
after all
but of course there are many many
microbes in fact the vast majority of
them existing outside of our bodies and
a hypothetical microbial banishment
would create some clear challenges you
might think that without the work of
diatoms and other photosynthetic
microbes we'd be at a risk of dying from
lack of oxygen pretty quickly and yes it
would be an eventual problem but it
turns out there's enough atmospheric
oxygen to sustain life for a pretty long
time Gilbert a new field note this as
more of a centuries-long backup plan
while we can maybe figure something else
out but if we're being honest with
ourselves we probably wouldn't make it
that long there are larger problems some
bacteria like Gnostic convert diatomic
nitrogen and the atmosphere into other
nitrogen containing compounds that
plants can actually use their
disappearance would severely reduce
photosynthesis and yes limit the further
release of oxygen into the atmosphere
but also it would just make it much
harder to grow plants which you will
remember we need for food meanwhile
macroscopic decomposers would have to
take on much more of the
of converting death into new ingredients
for life and we would also feel the loss
of other cycles that rely on microbes
like the processes that move phosphorus
across different layers of life the
interlocking nature of these microbe
based processes within their
environments mirrors our relatively new
understanding of how our own microbiome
dictates the interplay between microbes
and our bodies in fact scientists have
begun studying what they call the earth
microbiome not just a catalogue of the
diversity of microbes across the planet
but a broader understanding of how the
microbial composition is its own dynamic
thing that shapes and responds to the
world around it there's an ongoing
conversation about the possibility that
we are somewhere in the midst of a sixth
extinction event driven primarily by our
own human actions the characteristics of
this extinction are much more readily
observable on animals and plants than on
microbes but they are an important piece
of that extinction puzzle both in terms
of their future and our own many
microbes after all seem readily capable
of survival
like the trusty tardigrade the mascot of
all microbes who do what we would all
love to do when conditions are bad they
curl up in a protective cyst and lie
dormant
the question is if that really is what
it will take to survive what will the
world look like when they wake up
at the end of life in a world without
microbes Gilbert and Newfield describe a
world where nutrients and resources
become increasingly scarce a world where
we would need to rapidly fill the void
left by microbes with manufactured
alternatives designed to fill in
cavernous cracks they argue that we
might actually do okay for a few days
and maybe a small number of humans would
manage to last even for centuries but in
the long term for us humans at least the
prognosis is bleak but they also point
out that while microbes play a massively
important role in our world right now
there is a hypothetical where other
organisms adapt or evolve to reconfigure
those essential niches perhaps we would
be gone but life exceeds us and so does
its capacity for invention and then we
suppose earth would just have to get
ready for some new species to come along
develop technologies and look into the
fossil record to find what caused our
mass extinction and then make an
internet and then Internet videos about
us and how weird our world was back when
there were microbes
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and also thank you to
all of these people our patrons on
patreon who allow us to go on these deep
dives and understand more of how much we
rely on these little organisms so
various and so delightful if you want to
see more from our master of microscopes
James Weiss you can check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us here at journey to the
micro cosmos you can find us at
youtube.com slash micro cosmos